talk about the pandemic it never goes
away according to dr anthony fauci and
nothing ever gets better
he's still cautioning vaccinated
americans against
indoor dining eating and drinking
indoors in restaurants and bars
is that okay now no it's still not okay
for the simple reason that the level of
infection the dynamics of infection
in the community are still really
disturbingly
high and if you are vaccinated please
remember
that you still have to be careful and
not get involved in
crowded situations particularly indoors
where people are not wearing masks
it's exasperating how would the mix
message impact businesses
just trying to recover is that a
responsible statement let's bring in fox
news contributor dr marty mccary
dr mccary we were told last week by the
cdc if you're vaccinated
you can't transfer the virus we were
told you can't transfer the virus
from objects inanimate objects we were
wiping down our groceries for no reason
we should not even have to wear masks
let alone telling us not to go indoors
was that totally irresponsible well good
morning brian you're hearing a lot of
mixed messaging and as a result a lot of
the medical
officials are losing credibility and
we're seeing the infection right now
spread in five states among young people
and i think that's because a lot of the
guidance has lost credibility
look the israeli study is in now the our
own nih dr falgi's nih did not fund
these studies looking at transmission
but now we don't have to guess the data
is in and the risk of transmission from
that israeli study
is negligible and i can tell you brian
as a doc you got to give people
something to look forward to absolutely
if you just tell them they can't do
stuff
it's not right you got to tell them how
to do things safely and be on
in step with what they're going to do dr
mccary when you have a medical doctor on
you should have a psychologist on too
because also look at a behavior anyone
studying behavior
if i'm going to a bar and i've got to
leave at 11 o'clock because we know the
virus only spreads after 11
i go home where we've been told that in
home
spread is the bigger problem correct do
people want to ever gain plan this out
we're about to enter a big national
argument and that is when the hospitals
have basically no
covet patients but the virus continues
to circulate among young people who tend
to have asymptomatic infection or very
mild symptoms
is that a health emergency or not and
you're going to see a national argument
break out
over the month of may over that because
that's probably what's going to happen
over may
so there look there's trade-offs there's
it's not a matter of we're being
overly cautious as if caution is good
there's trade-offs and let me know
if you ever hear dr fauci or dr wolinski
ever talk about suicide from kids
getting shut out
from businesses being starved or from
the harm of profound isolation they
don't talk about that let me throw
a stat at you in march employment and
eating and drinking establishments
restaurants bars
1.8 million jobs below pre-pandemic
levels
we got 74 million people fully
vaccinated 22 percent of the population
over i think on saturday or sunday we
got 4 million in one day
yet we still have our medical officials
walking around with two masks
what kind of incentive is that to get
people who are on the fence
to get vaccinated what changes i still
have to get home and sit i have to go
home
and sit alone with a double mask look
let's make it very simple you get your
vaccine you wait a month for that
immunity to kick in
and live a normal life now if some
business
wants to have a mass policy for an
indoor public gathering just respect
that for a few more weeks until we get
to a better spot
but live a normal life and that's why
people should get vaccinated and that's
how we're going to deal with vaccine
hesitancy
liberate people don't tell us
that you cannot shed the virus once you
are vaccinated
and then tell us don't go anywhere don't
go to an establishment
do you have any restaurants are losing
zillions of dollars because of this
arbitrary 11 o'clock curfew and then you
have
america's doctor who has a doll of
himself
out there circulating which he thinks is
hysterical tell us not to go to those
places
do you know that people have leases due
restaurants want to hire employees
they order food and then you have dr
fauci telling people to stay home
that's totally irresponsible well i will
tell you brian i don't think it's
representative of how
everyday doctors think a small group of
people are making
all the decisions here and they may be
really good at virology
but they don't know anything about
implementation science about
public policy about poverty about
education
and they don't know anything about
rationing we haven't done a great job
rationing
scarce resources dr bakari thanks so
much appreciate it thanks so much brian
all right straight ahead fox news alert
a deadly mistake claims the life of 20
year old in minnesota but calls for due
process
are falling on deaf ears with unrest
overnight in a community on edge
well we'll ask our police panel about
what comes next